[Musica]
secondo voi possono le teorie sviluppate
da un grande scienziato come max e avere
a che fare con il pollo arrosto
oggi voglio proprio rispondere a questa
domanda ma soprattutto voglio farvi
capire come la scienza e la ricerca di
base anche teorica possano produrre
dispositivi metodi di uso quotidiano
ma chi era maxwell maxwell è uno dei
fisici e matematici più famosi di sempre
è colui che ha creato il ponte tra la
meccanica classica di isaac newton e la
relatività generale di einstein è il
padre fondatore della teoria
dell'elettromagnetismo nota come
equazioni di maxwell ma data anche un
contributo notevole la teoria cinetica
di gas
secondo la teoria di goldman maxwell ma
cosa c'entra maxwell con il pollo
arrosto
cosa possono centrare questa equazione
che vedete qui rappresentate e che
sembrano dei veri e propri geroglifici
con qualcosa che tutti noi conosciamo
che abbiamo consumato mangiato e gustato
in piedi in qualche occasione e marzo al
secondo me se lo immaginava già voi
tutti utilizzate le onde
elettromagnetiche quelle teorizzate da
max per guardare la tv per telefonare
per chattare per connettervi rete ma
forse non tutti sanno che le onde
elettromagnetiche interagiscono con la
materia trasmettendo la materia energia
e quindi riscaldando la materia e se
questa materia e cibo
le onde elettromagnetiche cuociono il
cibo il miglior apporto di nutrienti e
il minor tempo per incamerare questi
nutrimenti nutrimenti legate alla
cottura ha contribuito in modo
inequivocabile allo sviluppo
dell'intelligenza umana di reja lo
sviluppo dell'intera società
rispetto ad altri primati che non usano
cuocere il cibo ma la cottura rende il
cibo più morbido più gradevole al palato
più digeribile torniamo al nostro pollo
arrosto
quando voi dovete cucinare un pollo
arrosto lo mettete dentro al vostro
forno e utilizzate sostanzialmente tre
metodi di cottura tre metri di
riscaldamento quando azionate la ventola
utilizzate il metodo per convezione
quando invece adoperati il grill stata
adoperando un metodo che si chiama
riscaldamento per irraggiamento quando
invece lo mettete in una padella e
riscaldate la padella
oppure lo mettete sulla teglia del forno
la teglia che si scalda conduce o meglio
riscalda
il pollo e sia un riscaldamento per
conduzione il riscaldamento a microonde
è diverso da tutti questi metodi di
cottura si dice che un riscaldamento per
sorgenti interne ovvero è come se
andassimo a depositare all'interno del
pollo tante piccole fiammelle le quali a
poco alla volta riscaldano il pollo ma
qual è allora il meccanismo con il quale
viene questo riscaldamento
beh le molecole d'acqua presenti
all'interno di quasi tutti i cibi
reagiscono al campo elettromagnetico ad
una frequenza particolare 2450 megahertz
vuol dire che le molecole d'acqua
ruotano circa 2 miliardi e 450 milioni
di volte ogni secondo e in questa
rotazione producono attrito e l'attrito
produce calore e questo calore riscalda
il cibo ma guardate che non tutti i cibi
si comportano nella stessa maniera
rispetto a questa a queste onde
elettromagnetiche
ci sono alcuni cibi che sono
perfettamente trasparenti quindi
potreste lasciarli dentro il vostro
forme alla massima potenza anche per ore
e ore ore ma non si scaldano degli altri
invece che appena li inserite dentro il
forno a microonde
si scaldano immediatamente raggiungono
anche temperature piuttosto notevoli e
allora per farvi capire meglio questo
concetto
ho pensato di darvi una ricetta che
tutti voi potete fare a casa vostra
anche se non avete mai vinto un concorso
di masterchef potete prendere un pesce
il primo per il primo tentativo un pesce
di medie dimensioni un'orata un franzi
netto prendete una vasca d'acqua meglio
se l'acqua distillata mettete il pesce
dentro la vasca infatti modo che tutta
la vasca che tutto il pesce sia coperto
dall'acqua e poi inserite la vostra
vaschetta d'acqua dentro il congelatore
lo lasciate lì circa 10 ore se avete un
abbattitore magari un po meno e poi
togliete la vaschetta dal congelatore
bene a questo punto mettete la vaschetta
dentro al forno a microonde così
congelata mettete alla massima potenza e
lasciateli il tutto per circa 12 minuti
che cosa ottenete un blocco di ghiaccio
ma un blocco di ghiaccio s'è rotto in
una particolare posizione vicina al
pesce da quella rottura uscirà un
profumino perfetto di un pesce cotto al
vapore e cotto a puntino un filo d'olio
qualche patata e la cena è pronta ma
come mai viene tutto questo come vi
dicevo esistono dei particolari
materiali che sono più sensibili alle
microonde altri che lo sono meno quindi
praticamente quello che succede è che il
ghiaccio lasciapassare le microonde
arrivano fino al pesce il pesce invece
non è trasparente le microonde si scalda
scioglie l'acqua attorno al ghiaccio
quest'acqua diventa vapore e sia proprio
la cottura al vapore pesce al ghiaccio
fish in ice
ma guardate che la cottura a microonde è
una cottura che molto simile anzi del
tutto identica gli altri tipi di cottura
che cosa vuol dire cuocere un cibo che
cosa vuol dire riscaldare un materiale
da vuol dire agitare le molecole di cui
il materiale costituito ma se nel caso
dei metodi tradizionali convenzioni
irraggiamento e conduzione questa
agitazione avviene a partire dalla
superficie esterna del cibo e poi a poco
alla volta questa agitazione diffonde
verso l'interno
nel caso del forno a microonde
l'agitazione parte dall'interno ma anche
le microonde contribuiscono a tutte
quelle trasformazioni che ci consentono
di dire che il cibo cotto
anzi mantenendo la temperatura
superficiale e anche interna del cibo a
valori più bassi mantiene la cottura a
microonde il fido nutriente del cibo e
tutte quelle caratteristiche e proprietà
organolettiche del cibo stesso ma allora
è tutto bello quello che si può fare con
e microonde abbiamo capito che il
microonde efficiente perché riscalda
soltanto il cibo e non l'aria abbiamo
capito che ci consente di fare cotture
rapide in più mantiene le
caratteristiche organolettiche del cibo
è però tutti noi sappiamo che quando
inseriamo un cibo den trasforma
microonde tipicamente capita di avere
una parte che si scalda di più e
un'altra che si scalda di meno
questo sostanzialmente legato ad una
vecchia tecnologia che viene adoperata
tuttora in forno a microonde stiamo
parlando di una valvola che è stata
inventata nel dopoguerra
quindi che a 50 60 anni e che si chiama
magnetron e che viene utilizzata ancora
adesso è questa valvola non è né
intelligente né efficiente e tanto meno
controllabile però guardate che il
mercato dei forni a microonde è enorme
soltanto in europa ci sono una
quindicina di migliorini forni nelle
nostre case e c'è uno sviluppo enorme
anche per il futuro
e allora nei nostri laboratori
qui all'università di padova stiamo
costruendo il forno del futuro che cosa
farà il forno del futuro ma innanzitutto
sarà in grado di riconoscere il cibo che
metteremo dentro per cuocerlo ma sarà
anche in grado automaticamente di
riconoscere il livello di cottura e
quando il cibo sarà cotta a puntino
ma tramite i generatori elettronici di
microonde saremo in grado di distribuire
in maniera perfetta
l'energia all'interno del cibo e quindi
ad avere una temperatura uniforme per
tutto il cibo attraverso algoritmi
sofisticati saremo in grado di creare
una comune una combinazione di tutte
queste modalità di cottura convenzione
vapore ragionamento e così via
insieme alle microonde che ci
consentiranno di avere ricette da fare
invidia migliori chef del mondo ma il
foglio e il futuro sarà anche molto di
più la connessione internet veloce
il clown internet of things ci
consentiranno di condividere le ricette
in tutti i posti del mondo ma poi l'uso
di sensori di temperatura come quello
che vedete qui rappresentato questo è un
forno che già esiste nei nostri
laboratori
al posto del vetro ha un display che ci
fa vedere all'infrarosso quindi non più
nel visibile ci fa vedere all'infrarosso
la temperatura del cibo e quindi noi non
soltanto dovremo andare a sentire se
cibo caldo ma lo vedremo direttamente
quindi tutti questi sensori di
temperatura di umidità di peso ma anche
sensori nasi chimici che saranno in
grado di valutare gli elementi chimici
che si chiederanno all'interno della
camera del
tutti questi dati saranno elaborati da
algoritmi intelligenti e super veloci e
ci consentiranno di creare a casa nostra
ricetta da fare invidia i piatti di
punta dei migliori ristoranti stellati
ma guardate che la cucina del futuro
sarà anche molto social saremo in grado
ancora a casa nostra di provare ricette
di tradizioni e culture diverse
saremo in grado di cuocere piatti
collaborativi di piatti in
collaborazione in in collaborazione e
poi dal nostro forno tramite il display
del nostro forma del nostro forno saremo
in grado di seguire dei corsi di cucina
interattivi e online
ma il fondo del futuro sarà anche molto
di più non sarà più necessario né
gestirlo né condurlo insieme agli altri
elettrodomestici
anzi direi in collaborazione con tutti
gli altri elettrodomestici inglobando
tutte le caratteristiche degli altri
elettrodomestici sarà in grado di
soddisfare le nostre esigenze
avendo acquisito tramite tecniche di
machine learning intelligenza
artificiale realtà aumentata la
sensibilità della nostra mamma che
sapeva sempre cosa farci da mangiare e
ce lo faceva trovare pronta a tavola
quando tornavamo da scuola
mi piace pensare che maxwell avesse già
immaginato tutto questo finché scriveva
le sue equazioni sgranocchiando una
coscia di pollo
già